bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
jo-2020 coup de projecteur sur les
sportifs heavy noah qui porteront des
couleurs de l'équipe de france cet été à
tokyo ils sont plusieurs à pouvoir
prétendre à une médaille reportage à
suivre mm à une compétition d'arts
martiaux mixtes étaient organisées ce 10
juillet à maurepas d'une dizaine de
combats étaient au programme un
événement à huis clos retransmise via
internet
zoom dans ce magazine boeck se rend
compte à cassone ndam njikam le boxeur
professionnel franco camerounais était
ce vendredi 9 juillet dans les yvelines
le sportif de 37 ans ex champion wba wbo
des moyens est venu pour une séance
dédicace à fond il fleurit nous avons
profité de cette occasion pour revenir
sur sa carrière
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tb 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite cette émission
par une élection celle de brigitte
henriques à 50 en libye noise vient
d'être élue présidente du comité
national olympique et sportif français
avec 57 87 % des suffrages
elle succède à denis masseglia c'est une
grande première pour une femme son
objectif faire du sport un mode de vie
via 121 une mesure brigitte henriques
connaît très bien le département à
l'aîné à saint germain en laye a grandi
à poissy tout comme son frère le maire
karl olive
c'est d'ailleurs une ancienne joueuse de
football de la ville de poissy est liée
à jouer de 1983 à 1992
elle a ensuite joué à juvisy et soyaux
elle a ensuite gravi les échelons
jusqu'à devenir la numéro deux à la
fédération française de football dans
les années 2010 vous la verrez peut-être
cet été à tokyo la présidente du cnosf
sera en repérage pour préparer les jo de
on continue à parler jiho les jeux
olympiques de tokyo sont programmés de
ce vendredi à 23 juillet à ce dimanche 8
août plusieurs zibinoh avons participé à
ce rendez vous planétaire et ils veulent
tous brillé sur la scène internationale
tour d'horizon à montage de rémi
lefebvre cet été les yvelines seront
bien représentés pendant ces jeux
olympiques de tokyo le contingent
évinois devrait être composée d'une
dizaine de sportifs parmi eux trois
triathlètes du club de poissy seront de
la partie dorian coninx cassante
beaugrand et léonie périodes cette
dernière connaîtra ses premiers jo
c'est un honneur de représenter fois ci
parce qu'en effet pas je les côtoie
depuis
depuis je pense 2010 par là donc c'est
vraiment ma c'était le but et on a
réussi en golf antoine ros nord du golfe
de la boulie à versailles représentera
la france sur cette compétition après
une année 2009 un teint de haut niveau
une victoire au qatar masters
à 28 ans le sportif espère remporter une
médaille en aviron la rameuse claire
bové de l'association sportive mantaise
fait partie des favoris dans son sport
pour un podium cet été un podium ce
serait franchement c'est un beau rêve là
les armes pour se battre dans la
catégorie et pour faire de belles choses
donc c'est un beau rêve mais
un petit peu réaliste quand même un
cyclisme sur piste ils seront plusieurs
à partir au japon la fédération
française a décidé de miser sur la
jeunesse avec 4 pépite mathilde de gros
21 ans sébastien vie j'ai 24 ans
rayonner la halle 22 ans et florian
grings bovins en dix ans yeoh bce
skyteam vous sert le réel objectif
une carrière sportive de haut niveau qui
est la médaille aux jeux olympiques donc
très content mais il ya encore beaucoup
de travail pour aller chercher la plus
belle des médailles en bmx cinq sportifs
qui s'entraînent sur le stadium à côté
du vélodrome nationale vont s'envoler
pour les jeux on retrouve dans la
sélection manon valentino axel etienne
silva andré le triple champion du monde
joris daudet ou encore romain mahieu je
pense que pour chaque sportif de haut
niveau participe aux jeux olympiques
c'est le plus gros objectif d'une
carrière donc super content ça va juste
la première étape
maintenant on va y aller pour une
médaille ce qui est voilà ce qui est le
rêve est et pourquoi on travaille tous
les jours
en judo à 34 ans guillaume chaîne
participera à ses premiers jeux
olympiques après avoir été remplaçant en
2016 à rio
judoka espère faire briller son club de
sartrouville au niveau international
dans la catégorie des moins de 73 kg
l'objectif comme chacun des athlètes qui
se présente aux jeux olympiques
j'espère pour eux c'est d'aller
décrocher l'or maintenant moi c'est mes
premiers jeux olympiques donc
c'est déjà une petite victoire en soit
maintenant j'y vais pas pour figurer non
plus en boxe maiva hamadouche a réussi à
se qualifier pour les jeux olympiques la
sportive du boxing club saint quentin en
yvelines sera dans la catégorie des
moins de 60 kg une grande première pour
cette boxeuse passé professionnel en
c'était surtout quand on était en boxeur
professionnel jamais vraiment laissé les
jeux olympique de côté parce que savoir
quand on est des sportifs
quand on est professionnel on n'a pas le
droit de se présenter aux jo 100 m big
ça s'est ouvert pour les en euros à rio
la sévère pour les femmes également
l'apport tokyo j'avais vraiment tirer un
trait sur ces jo sur les légions tout
simplement
donc en fait pour moi c'est une chance
inestimable
enfin en balles versailles et valentin
porte devrait faire partie de l'équipe
de france à tokyo champion du monde avec
les experts en 2015 et 2017
l'arrière droit espère remporter cette
fois ci un titre olympique avec la
sélection tricolore
ces civils noirs vont-ils tous performer
à tokyo réponse à partir du 23 juillet
aux jeux olympiques cet été en cyclisme
on retrouvera également à benjamin
thomas le pistard de 25 ans qui a vécu
quelques années à trappes sera aligné
sur les épreuves d'endurance il fera
partie des favoris de l'omnium pour l'or
il a déjà remporté trois titres de
champion du monde d'endurance et cinq
titres de champion d'europe chez les
filles on retrouvera klara copponi du
vélo-club elancourt
saint-quentin-en-yvelines team vous sert
à 22 ans elle sera alignée sur les
épreuves d'omnium et de madison espère
réaliser un podium
cet été on va maintenant par les mêmes à
une compétition d'arts martiaux mixtes
étaient organisées ce samedi 10 juillet
au sdcl center de maurepas une dizaine
de combats étaient au programme de la
soirée
retour sur cet événement des images de
patrick jacques de dixmude
une cage de la sueur des coups
spectaculaires le sdcl center de
maurepas organise un gala d'arts
martiaux mixtes ce samedi 10 juillet au
rendez-vous de mma faisait partie du ffa
a challenge nous ici on ouvert depuis
neuf ans et ça fait passer notre coeur
de métier donc pouvoir combattre pourra
revoir les gars qui sont entraînés dur
toute l'année pour aller s'exprimer avec
d'autres personnes en france c'est
génial au programme dix combats
professionnels de la catégorie des moins
de 57 kg au moins 220 kg dont deux
combats féminins
parmi les participants un local qui
s'entraînent dans cette salle de
maurepas c'est un bon niveau
il ya beaucoup de jeunes combattants qui
débute le niveau ce soir va être élevé
je pense pour permettre au plus grand
nombre de voir les combats le
rendez-vous à huit clos était retransmis
en direct sur une plateforme de
streaming
il faut que ça soit du live parce que
comme pour l'instant on évite les
regroupements de trop de personnes de
pouvoir l'élargir et que tout le monde
puisse le voir en même temps qu'on le
fait pas c'est génial on n'a pas
l'impression des dettes est d'être
encore à hugo quoi on est malgré tout on
a tout le monde qui peut suivre les
internautes ont notamment pu voir le
club de maurepas brille également dans
la cage avec la victoire de l'illinois
maxime flop si oui où deuxième round par
ko
très attendu le bon timing et j'ai senti
le coup et après je vais donner
et comme on dit ça fait mouche donc
voilà je suis très content aujourd'hui
mais j'ai encore beaucoup de travail à
faire à notre combat devrait être
organisée en octobre dans les yvelines
avec du public cette fois ci si les
conditions sanitaires le permettent on
continue à parler de sport de combat
hassan ndam njikam le boxeur
professionnel franco à cameron et était
ce vendredi dans les yvelines sportif de
37 ans ex champion wba wbo des moyens
est venu pour une séance dédicace à
fontenay le fleury
nous avons profité de cette occasion
pour revenir sur sa carrière et surtout
ses objectifs et sa reconversion dans le
mma c'est notre interview express grande
fierté de toutes ces réalisations depuis
le début de mon arrivée en france
jusqu'aujourd'hui de mon ascension est
de mon championnat du monde depuis 2010
et où je suis reste au top niveau
jusqu'en 2021
donc je pense vraiment que voilà je ne
peux qu'avoir une seule satisfaction
c'est la ccc la fierté
on peut vous souvenir c'est c'est mon
premier voyage à new york devant mike
tyson devant des grands champions et qui
m'applaudissent quand je monte sur un
ring et que je fais je fais d un beau
combat devant daisy devant des grands
boxeurs et vraiment c'est m'a poussé ma
peau grossièretés et aussi de rencontrer
floyd mayweather à las vegas c'est sait
des choses aujourd'hui qui équivalent
cher étant une hyper actif j'ai voulu
tout de suite sollicité mon corps si
quelque chose d'autre et comme j'avais
aimé le mma et que je devais revenir
forcément à la fin de ma carrière pour
faire ce pour faire ce sport c'est ça a
été beaucoup plus vite et précipitée que
que d'habitude donc voilà c'est pour ça
j'ai signé avec la ligue garès quatre
combats et j'ai reçu dernièrement et un
contrat de résiliation tout simplement
parce que pendant locaux vides
l'allégresse a eu des difficultés ils
ont déposé le bilan
donc je suis en train de voir pour une
autre fédération peut-être en arabie
saudite puissance abu dhabi et donc pour
partie donc bientôt vous allez me voir
dans une cage de mma en attendant j'ai
encore de belles choses à faire en boxe
et je suis un éternel apprenti parce que
le fait de repartir à zéro avec l'om
mans me me redonne mais mais mais jours
deux jeunes garçons j'ai l'impression de
renaître dans un nouveau sport et de
redevenir jeunes parce que j'apprends
parfois je me retrouve avec des des plus
jeunes que moi et qui me met à l'amendé
au niveau mm
parce que je suis un débutant et il faut
avoir cette maturité et et la tête sur
les épaules de dire on n'est pas en ne
sait rien on était champion du monde
peut être mais à un moment on est
débutant on reste dans les sports de
combat focus sa présence sur l'activité
d'un entrepreneur évinois franck romeo a
créé à ben dax start-up installé à
plaisir qui fabrique des bandages pour
les entraînements de boxe il fournit
plusieurs athlètes français qui sont à
tokyo à cet été un reportage de nicolas
landry faut savoir c'est qu'à trois
zones à protéger un le poignet le pouce
et la traite icd métacarpe
voici la dernière version du bandage de
protection des boxeurs un produit
fabriqué par la start plaisir oise bande
axes des équipements utilisés par des
athlètes français comme tony yoka
estelle you came ou sli ou encore
sofiane oumiha ils seront aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo
nyoka ça s'est fait via sa femme estelle
et aucun mosley avec qui j'ai commencé à
travailler
il ya de ça m'a quand elle est passé pro
en fait quand elle est passée pro elle
avait besoin justement d'avoir un cat
man dans son équipe et elle cherchait à
avoir une bonne protection demain pour
ses entraînements
elle est venue ici dans notre atelier
pour justement essayer le produit
on a travaillé avec elle ça s'est très
bien passé donc et ensuite forcément
j'ai été amené à rencontrer tony qui
apportait du coup le bandage dans sa
deuxième version dans la nouvelle
version la version actuelle est là aussi
adhérer aux produits franck romeo a créé
bon dax en 2010 cette spécialiste dans
la conception des bandages de boxer il a
voulu leur faciliter la tâche
objectif protéger et faire gagner du
temps aux sportifs
si des champions du monde et des
champions olympiques comme tony hawk a
comme lomachenko ou font confiance pour
protéger leur outil de travail c'est que
le produit répond vraiment à une attente
en plus de travailler avec des sportifs
de renom en boxer en mma il a fournit
aussi les boxeurs de la team farrugia
d'elancourt comme marvin petit houga du
school où la volonté devant dax et
surtout de protéger les mains à
l'entraînement parce que c'est à
l'entraînement il ya beaucoup de
blessures c'est là où il ya la
répétition des coups et ça à
l'entraînement que les blessures secret
pour cette société l'objectif à terme
est d'obtenir une homologation des
autorités de la boxe pour utiliser son
équipement en compétition de la boxe
encore libinois tony hawk assurera sur
les rings en septembre le boxeur
originaire de chanteloup les vignes va
affronter le croate est tard à millas le
10 septembre prochain pour défendre son
titre de l'union européenne des lourds
et combattra dans un lieu mythique sur
le central de roland garros une grande
première depuis septembre 1973 un combat
organisé par alain delon en annonce près
de 15000 spectateurs sur le central si
la crise sanitaire le permet tony hawk à
29 ans affiche pour le moment un bilan
de dix victoires en dix combats dont 8
par ko en football
une information à mercato c'était
pressenti depuis plusieurs jours c'est
désormais officiel matteo guendouzi
originaire de poissy rejoint l'olympique
de marseille sous forme de prêt avec une
option d'achat estimée à 11 millions
d'euros
le jeune international français de 22
ans formé au paris saint germain a passé
sa visite médicale
il connaîtra son quatrième club chez les
professionnels après lorient à arsenal
et le hertha berlin lui minois devrait
être titulaire à marseille là
la prochaine toujours au chapitre
mercato mais cette fois ci en basket
c'est fait victor wanyama natif du
chesnay quittent nanterre pour
villeurbanne le joueur de 17 ans qui
culmine à 2 mètres 19 vient de s'engager
officiellement avec l'asvel pour les
trois prochaines saisons
tony parker propriétaire du club a dit
lors de sa signature que victor était le
plus gros potentiel du basket français
de ces vingt dernières années
l'année dernière il a tourné avec
nanterre à 6 8 points 4 7 rebonds en 17
minutes de moyenne par match de quoi
attirer également les regards des clubs
de nba
victor webb anyama qui a également
brillé avec la sélection u19 de l'équipe
de france en chine
les tricolores sont allés jusqu'à la
finale de la coupe du monde mais ils ont
perdu 83 à 81 face aux etats-unis le
magret un immense victor webb anyama
viennois pourtant inscrit 22 points pris
8 rebonds et réalisé 8 contre dans cette
finale mais il est sorti avant la fin
après avoir commis trop de fautes les
français échouent donc dans la quête
d'un premier titre mondial
on continue ce 7,8 sport part du
baseball les cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux joueront tout au
long de cet été dans le championnat de
première division pour nous parler des
cougars nous avons avec nous le
président franck lecarpentier bonsoir
bonsoir
alors le championnat a débuté
tardivement le 13 juin pour l'instant on
est encore en début de championnat c'est
bien ça alors on a passé le début de
championnat on est pile poil la moitié
est du coup une arrivée tardive au wynn
arrivée tardive sur le championnat
puisque d'habitude on peut manger début
avril
car entraîné pas mal de problématiques
tout simplement puisque ça nous a aussi
été annoncée par doucement donc ça
quelques petits problèmes de recrues
alors à la 5e journée vous êtes
actuellement à quatrième de la poule
avec seulement deux victoires en huit
matches comment vous pouvez qualifier ce
début de saison pour les cougars de
monty bretonneux alors je vais essayer
de rester pas trop directif en fait
c'est bon c'est pas forcément reste le
résultat qu'on attendait
maintenant faut avoir les pieds sur
terre on a beaucoup de difficulté re de
recrutement le championnat nous a été
annoncée seulement animés comme vous le
savez on est toujours en course et pas
mal de joueurs étrangers
on a du mal à faire venir avec la
situation sanitaire actuelle est
également on a perdu quelques
internationaux qui préférait mutés dans
d'autres
donc on ne s'en sort pas si mal que ça
alors le coleader vous at il perturbé
dans votre préparation
ah bah y'a pas eu de préparation cette
année tout course et on a commencé
direct le championnat pas de matches
amicaux donc on a fait que de
l'entraînement avant la mise en pratique
en était plein d'espoir la première
journée puisque rouen s'était présenté
chez nous pour la première journée de
champions de france
depuis des années on a réussi à faire
une victoire une défaite on fait deux
matchs par jour malheureusement la suite
a pas été dans la même veine quelles
sont vos ambitions pour ce championnat
2021 déjà deux alors on va faire tout
semble ne pas être relégable déjà ce
serait une catastrophe pour nous là on
va avoir pas mal de renforts qui vont
arriver puisque la situation sanitaire
s'est un petit peu débloquer au fil des
mois donc on va essayer de faire en
sorte de bien finir le championnat là il
nous reste huit matches à jouer dans
prendre un maximum possible et de se
qualifier et éventuellement pour
l'épreuve si c'est possible voire sur le
second tableau au moins pour faire
vraiment une mauvaise vous avez joueurs
pour réussir cet objectif
ah bah écoutez là en tout cas le
prochain match et tarbes ont donc chez
le champion de france en titre
on a quatre parties arrivent de
l'effectif qui était attendue donc en
sachant qu'on joue à 9
la moitié de l'équipe qui va changer je
pense que les choses vont tellement
changé appartement on a l'équipe qui
maintenant c'est pas pour dénigrer ce
qu'ont fait les joueurs de réserve où
ils sont là pour ça mais il manque
d'expérience en d1 on peut le dire c'est
fini pour le haut du classement où rien
n'est terminé
ça va être très très dur sait on a déjà
on est à deux victoires
l'adversaire le plus proche on a déjà
finck
là ça va être décisif la prochaine en
doute le comte contraction au roi alors
vous allez jouer quatre matches cet été
contre aux rencontres sa vie sur un jeu
le puck de paris le stade toulousain
ce sont des matchs plutôt abordable à
parvenir sur la compris baron et rouen
est toujours favori quoi qu'il arrive
savigny sur orge avait pas fait le même
pari que nous ils avaient fait leur
recrutement en fonction d'une
potentielle de saison début mai donc
c'était une des hypothèses qui étaient
sur la table
ils sont très très forts cette année
pour le puck et toulouse c'est beaucoup
plus abordable avec une équipe complète
ce n'est pas trop perturbante de jouer
tout l'été vous n'êtes pas forcément
habitué à ça elle souvent une petite
coupure et une reprise en septembre
oui d'habitude on a on a trois semaines
de kuyt donc là on n'a pas le choix
c'est très très perturbant après la
fédération a fait ce qu'elle pouvait
dans le sens où il ya un championnat
d'europe des nations au mois de
septembre donc
et du coup le championnat va même être
interrompue puisque à la fin du
championnat le champion d'europe des
nations commence et nous ferons au
players juste après le championnat
d'europe des nations
donc c'est vraiment très très perturbant
effectivement cette année après on a la
chance de faire une saison par rapport
aux rapaces est-ce qu'on peut venir voir
les matches au stade jean maréchal de
mantilles bretonneux cet été aujourd'hui
tout à fait alors on a on a des critères
de jours j'ai un petit peu comme tout le
monde c'est 65 % de mémoire toujours
obligations du mas comme partout en
france
donc on peut s'installer par un groupe
d'amis tribune mais ça se passera très
bien un peu de public
et comment ça se passe en général et une
journée type quand on vient voir du
baseball à montigny-le-bretonneux alors
la journée type tout simplement le
premier match commence à 11h donc ce
sont des matches qui joue en général
deux heures et demie nous l'avantagé
qu'on a en tribunes c'est qu'on a une
buvette qui est assez sympathique qui
nous permet de servir le public donc en
général et jean manche en tribunes et
enchaîne avec le deuxième match
donc le deuxième match en général
commencé à 14h au max donc en gros on
peut passer toute la journée au stade
jean maréchal c'est bien ça tout à fait
et on l'espère sous le soleil ce que la
le mois de juillet commence pas d'une
manière terrible mais on espère les
meilleurs auspices pour le mois d'août
oui je précise on ne joue pas
normalement c'est ça s'il pleut non non
c'est en fait c'est très dangereux là
bas la tendance à déraper et comme nos
bals sont excessivement dure le moins de
contact avec un joueur que dans le pire
des cas être fatale
ce qu'on ne souhaite pas donc en général
de quand il peut effectivement on
s'interroge une dernière question qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour cet
été pour l'époux gardons tibre de monty
bretagne bien sûr ouais mais que le
cowitz envahit déjà parce que c'est pour
tous les sports qu'on peut le souhaiter
d'un an
on souhaite vraiment déjà que l'équipe
prenne plaisir à jouer que le public
viennent nous soutenir que la situation
reprenne son cours en là on est vraiment
sur des saisons vraiment particulière
dont on soit qui je suis les plus merci
à vous d'être intervenu dans cette
émission on suivra avec attention les
résultats des cougars de montigny le
bretonneux cet été et on espère qu'ils
seront très bon évidemment merci à vous
franck le carpentier a rendez vous à
noter dans vos agendas une nouvelle
édition de la diagonale des yvelines est
programmée le 11 septembre prochain
l'événement permet de traverser le
département en trahi par des chemins
forestiers quatre distances sont au
programme dont un à 82 km les
organisateurs attendent près de 500
personnes si les conditions sanitaires
le permettent on écoute l'un des
organisateurs au micro de tv 78 il nous
présente le
septe on avait lancé une première
édition en 2010 9 qui a eu lieu c'était
la traversée de du département donc diag
diagonale des yvelines un petit
parallèle à la diagonale des fous mais
pas de comparaison la comparaison
s'arrête là mais c'est un concept de
traverser les yvelines entrailles
partout les chemins forestiers des
yvelines il y en a il y en a un bon
paquet et cette année ça sera du nord au
sud et non du sud au nord première
édition on partait de rochefort on
arrivait à mantes-la-jolie là sur cette
édition on partira de breuil boisrobert
à un petit village à côté de mantes la
jolie
un autre rendez-vous la ville
d'elancourt va organiser pour la
première fois les l'encours championne
strain le rendez-vous sera organisé le
16 octobre prochain au programme une
course de 13 km destiné au trailer
confirmés ou amateurs
sur le parcours les sportifs auront une
ascension de laconique d'elancourt le
futur site olympique du vtt en 2024 et
une traversée de france miniature on
regarde cette vidéo de présentation
[Musique]
vous pouvez vous inscrire pour la
compétition sur le site internet
d'elancourt on termine par une dernière
information vient de l'apprendre
libinois antoine ros leurs pensionnaires
du golf de la boulie à versailles a
appris sa qualification pour le prochain
british open qui se déroulera du 15 au
18 juillet au royal st george une grande
première pour lui le versailles a
affirmé sa joie d'être dans le champ de
joueurs sur les réseaux sociaux
antoine ros nord est actuellement le 84e
joueur mondial il sera accompagné par
quatre autres français dont le numéro un
français à victor à perez c'est la fin
de cette émission à merci de l'avoir
suivi très bel été sur tv 78
[Musique]